hey dr. Wallach how you doing sir fine
thank you how can we help you sir okay
um I've been on dialysis now since 2006
and um they told me my doctor told me
that my kidneys are just about me
totally shut down because of them some
chemicals got into on my job okay wait a
minute stop stop stop
how many days a week are you getting a
dialysis three
well I do it every night now I'll do a
peritoneal everybody okay okay and let's
see here
are you urinating yes I still do urinate
there's not much urine
okay so it is reduced in volume yes sir
quite a bit okay how much you weigh
about 225 and how tall are you sir five
seven okay at five seven I'd like to see
away maybe 165 so it wouldn't hurt to
lose about 50 60 pounds and that'll help
and Charmaine what would you do for
Gerald here he's on dialysis he's doing
home peritoneal dialysis every night and
so what would you give him to support
healthy kidney function for that I for
those are shoes I would give him to
healthy brain and heart packs and then I
would add the ultimate daily classic and
a vitamin d3 okay and yeah okay well you
get an A+ here dear and what's going on
here Gerald is when you have kidney
failure dan do you have any other issues
any high blood pressure diabetes
arthritis anything like that okay that
was the initial calls on the chemicals I
was running my job was causing my
pressure to be us all the time and I was
at all kinds of blood pressure medicine
and nothing was working I mean nothing
was working and they got so point well
I've been real bad and another reason
I'm asking because when you're when
you're getting dialysis oftentimes your
ginnis will release a hormone called
renin our enin and to raise your blood
pressure to get more blood coming
through to kill kidneys charmaine when
you have quote kidney failure unquote
and you're put on dialysis whether it's
home perineal diocese or you have to go
to the lab three days a week what what
is really happening there
well the apparent arteries that feed the
kidneys dirty bladder are getting
plugged up and the kidneys aren't
getting dirty blood to clean and they're
mad so they force the blood pressure up
with a hormone called renin that verses
a blood pressure because they think
they'll get blood to clean and they
won't and then doctors give you a blood
anti blood pressure medicine and then
the kidneys dis release more running so
it's a vicious cycle it'll never end
yeah okay so char's exactly right there
gerald so what we suggest is get rid of
all the bad stuff which contributed to
plugged arteries which are probably
plugged in your kidneys not bringing the
dirty blood into the kidneys and most of
the time there's really nothing wrong
with your kidneys and so the blood will
shows that your kidneys are not
filtering because they're not getting
the dirty blood to the plugged arteries
it's like changing your tub out your tub
plugs and really need to get the
roto-rooter guy out there to get the
willow roots out of your drain there's
nothing wrong with the tub and so as
your body weight to healthy brain and
heart packs four months to a healthy
brain and heart pressure month full dose
everything twice a day
vitamin d3 three of those capsules twice
a day two bottles a month
the ultimate daily classic tablets two
bottles of that a months you can take
three of those tablets twice a day or
two three times a day for a total of six
a day that's gonna support healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries and
support healthy blood pressure and then
give us a call every couple weeks and
anytime you could get information the
doctor on your creatine levels and also
your grammarian or filtration rate
numbers and we'll walk you through this
we see a lot of good results dealing
with Dallas's patients